my babies are gone i know that um
my time played a part in my son
feeling he could test something right
you know and i feel guilty about that
in the last nine years bobby's lost his
son his ex whitney
and their daughter bobby christina all
in part due to drugs
how much you miss her there's no way to
express
how much i miss my daughter in our last
interview bobby wanted justice after
bobby christina's boyfriend nick gordon
was ruled legally responsible for her
death
but wasn't jail for him he'll get his
god don't like ugly less than two years
later
nick died from a heroin overdose and
bobby blames him
for his other loss he was the only one
there with both
uh situations with my ex-wife
and with my daughter and they both died
the same way
so you think that he killed whitney
as well i believe so bitter sweet
maurice you and whitney
had an abusive volatile relationship the
violence that we
we incurred was using we abused drugs
right
and alcohol we struggled really hard as
a couple
to get clean for ourselves stop
getting my face get out my face what do
you think that bobby
would say to whitney now
she's definitely missed god has a plan
that
you know i can't question it was already
written in the books
[Music]